No matter what knitting patterns you use,
adjusting the length of your
sleeves isn't difficult.
Use the Knit It Now Magic formula
tool and let us do the math for you.
I want to make my sleeve three
inches shorter than the pattern.
The original pattern length is 16.75 inches plus 2 inches for ribbing.
I'm going to keep my wrist measurement
the same at nine inches,
and I'm going to keep the upper
arm measurement the same at 14.5.
All I want to adjust is the sleeve length.
I'll make it 13.75 and keep the ribbing at 2 inches.
I'll use the Magic Formula tool in inches.
Now, the shaping is going to be
for both sides of my sleeve.
I'll enter my gauge.
The starting width is the wrist
measurement of 9 inches and the ending
width is the upper arm measurement of 14.5 inches.
I want the shaped section
of my sleeve to be 13.75.
Here are my knitting instructions.
All of the increases are evenly spaced
and my sleeve will be the perfect length.